any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic it's a
pleasure to welcome none other than
Professor Janna Levin to the into the
impossible podcast Janna where are you
joining us which bunker are you in right
now at the Pioneer works bunker it's
really quite interesting because the
students have all evacuated and a lot of
the faculty have evacuated so it's the
quietest we call it upstate Manhattan
yeah yeah there's a there's a book I
think called like once upon a time or in
New York or something in a characterize
as New York and the 1800s it's a
wonderful a kind of historical fan
fiction to New York and it you know
talks about the fields around Broadway
up in the Upper West Side quite lovely
but but it is a treat and thank you so
much for making time I know it's a very
frantic frenetic time for all of us in
the faculty set and but and you
especially all the hats and balls that
you juggle in the air so so specifically
I want to give you your official
introduction that gen 11 is that Claire
tau professors at our toe or how do you
say tau professor of physics and
astronomy
she's a theoretical cosmologist she's a
professor at Barnard College Columbia
University and she earned her PhD in
theoretical physics at MIT a small
Technical College in Massachusetts and
her Bachelor of Science as well with a
concentration in philosophy at Barnard
where she graduated Phi Beta Kappa like
that that's great
much of our work deals with looking for
evidence supports a proposal that our
universe might be finite in size and
that of course subject of your least
startling you know just just phenomenal
book how the universe got its spots
which deeply influenced me in the
writing of my book and showed me that
that a you know young scientist could
could effectively write what you know it
was in a series of letters a memoir and
really captured the spirit of what it
feels like to be a human being doing
science so it's such a treat we've never
met in person we were kind of talking
about that it feels like we should have
met but we never did we have mutual
friends in common
Stephon Alexander Amanda Veltman who
speaks so glowingly about your her time
with you as well and it's a treat to
have you here so thank you so much Janna
thank you so much I really appreciate
your kind words you know books are these
things you kind of like their messages
in a bottle you launch them out into the
world and it's always amazing to hear
where they land there yeah that's right
and so we're going to talk a little bit
about books but the first thing I really
wanted to get to is is that you where as
I said many different hats or however
you want to describe it and what one
thing that characterizes your work is is
really you know kind of at the pinnacle
of scientific research but also you know
without parallel doing outreach to the
public and I want to just kind of pick
your brain as someone who aspires to do
what you're doing to both be you know
hardcore physicist as you are in the in
the theoretical front I'm trying to be
in the experimental front how do you
manage to do that
what was that always a goal of yours to
be able to do both and do you feel like
it's an obligation to do both so can you
share your philosophy as an educator to
the public as well as to your students
yes sir I I never really think of it as
outreach so I think that this is a funny
thing we say to scientists oh now you're
not being a scientist now you're doing
this other thing called outreach and I
just I've never really understood that
so if you're an artist and you spend a
lot of your time in your studio toiling
away and it's you have these ideas and
you know it and then and then you make
work and then you exhibit it nobody's
like oh look at you doing outreach yeah
we consider that participation and
culture to be part of the part of the
creative process and part of learning
and and then communicating and being
engaged in a you know cultural sphere
completely natural and I've always felt
as very Natural Science of course I want
to talk about my work and of course it
starts out just your friends talking to
your friends about your crazy work and
trying to translate and how I would when
I would have that you know over like
happy hour with my friends translating
to them some something I'm trying to
understand
I would have my own epiphanies I would
have my own kind of a moment of deeper
understanding in that process of
translating and it was just something I
liked to do and I don't consider it I
considered another creative project but
a natural extension of good scientific
behavior do I think it should be an
obligation I absolutely do not I think
every not everyone wants to do that and
and absolutely would be ridiculous if it
was an obligation so I really think you
have to have in you this urge to write
urge to use language this is sort of it
has to feel like a creative project of
its own which is a natural consequence
of work of being a scientist and one of
your major projects is pioneer words can
you tell us a little bit about pioneer
works for those on the west coast yeah
so actor pioneer works is a cultural
center it has it's completely unique to
my knowledge in that it's has arts music
and science all as major pillars not
trying to do some art make scientists be
artists or anything like that it's just
we consider science part of culture and
we bring science to this cultural sphere
we have a lot of public conversations
they're surprisingly popular they're
absolutely packed we have people
standing and sitting in a you know
pioneer it's is going through some
upgrades but we had no AC one hot summer
an event an animal consciousness like
1,200 people nobody budged for the hour
and a half and so we have this really
devoted awesome audience and recently we
launched so I'm director of Sciences and
so I felt out the the sciences and
recently we've lucked launched something
called the broadcast which is going to
be our what we're calling like a virtual
assembly and where it's a very beta
version it's real kind of emergency mode
because we hadn't planned on launching
so fast but the current crisis has has
changed our timeline as they say so we
have this this quickly launch version
broadcast that that just is now reaching
out some of our archives and and our
ideas both from science art and also for
music so I think that's you know it's
it's a unique attribute of this and it's
all free right it's most of the all
these programs are open to the public
and free and you have an extensive
library catalog of videos that you
posted with Nobel laureates with artists
with you know famous scientists from all
these different spheres including our
mutual friend Brian Greene we just
featured a live conversation with Brian
we released the video on the broadcast
it was just a couple weeks ago right
that's great so I want the segue using
Brian and and kind of paralleling what
you do with him and maybe contrasting
with with other people in the science
communications business in that you know
sometimes people will trot out somebody
like Neil deGrasse Tyson to opine and
one thing I really love about Neil is
that he'll always say well why don't you
ask the scientist who did the results
first and I wanted to you know segue
into that in just a minute
popping that's going around the
interfere as we speak about exciting
things that have tangential
relationships to the work that you and I
do but first have you noticed
and do you ever perceive that there's
sort of this maybe slight denigration or
lowering of a steam if somebody you know
chooses to popularize science and does
something in the mass market as they say
you know versus or - what if you do
believe that's true do you attribute it
- I do sense it even to the extent you
know that there might be a jealousy of
someone like Neil deGrasse Tyson who's
so outstanding at popularization and
branching on admittedly he doesn't
practice as a scientist as you do
anymore
but how do you bridge that gap was that
something you were worried about you
speak a little bit about that after the
writing of how the universe got its
spots I remember you talking about that
but how do you look back on it now that
book is about 15 years 20 years old now
did you worry about you know kind of the
level of respect or esteem or maybe not
vitriol but jealousy yeah go ahead
oh sure I was
told in no uncertain terms not to do
this I was just fresh out of graduate
school and and I was told absolutely by
people who cared about me and meant well
do not do this this will be the end of
your career and that was a very strong
15 years ago that was a very strong we
widely held opinion and even when I went
through my tenure process as a professor
I was told and quite absurdly if you ask
me but that none of my books would be
considered in my dossier yeah they just
not be included they would they would be
mined enough the attitude was sort of
like well we won't penalize you so
you're getting a you're getting off
lightly right not actively penalize you
but we won't consider it and this is
crazy this is like one of my books when
a pan award and you know if I was in if
I walked over to the next building I'd
get tenure on the basis of that panel
heard um so it is you know it's a lot of
mixed messages but and it took me kind
of a long time to find a position in
which I felt I had support from my
college and you know but that that they
knew what they were getting and they
didn't tell me to stop her to quit was
very important and so so I feel very
supported where I am but I do think the
tide has also turned and it's turned in
part because of people like Brian you
know Kip Thorne wrote this wonderful
book Lenny Susskind has a great book
black hole wars um Sean Carroll writes
wonderful books out so I think that that
the respect for the quality of the
writing went up and with it a sort of
greater acceptance that this was a valid
aspect of of what what somebody should
be doing when promoting science to the
world and so I do think it's turned not
a hundred percent because we've all
gotten raps on the knuckles at various
times and you could ask that whole group
that I just mentioned that they've
gotten a rap on the knuckles more than
once
but we've also sort of changed the
culture in that in that way and and now
everybody wants to write a book yeah
right yeah so now I'm waiting for it you
cannot get tenure unless you write a
book in the physics department but it's
gonna be oh we've always thought this
was really important that's right it'll
be first dismissed as as crazy and then
accepted as obvious right yes so that's
yeah I always find it ironic because
many of us got interested in science
because of the great popularization zuv
you know people like Stephen Hawking and
Brian Greene and Sir Roger Penrose all
these folks that influenced me and I
know a great impact in your life as well
and yet even our scientist colleagues
who don't write a book you know it's
kind of like you know eventually it
might be like we described them as not
having you know two different cohorts
and and and we'll say the ones that
haven't written books but I do feel like
it's it's sort of you know sometimes
there is this notion you know of well
you must not have you know time for real
science if you're doing if you're doing
these extreme extraneous projects like
I'm doing this podcast or writing my
book or what have you but then you look
at you know how poor a job I just had on
Eric Weinstein on the podcast just this
week and he you know saying you know
physicists are really not not good at
making use of the vast array of tools
that they have at their disposal and by
battey means you have these incredibly
the most fascinating things ever
you know contemplated by the human mind
and we're like the best at were the
worst at public relations and I feel
like because we're so bad and it is hard
to do what you do and I remember Brian
Greene you know telling me that you know
he had you know receive coaching for you
know how to how to communicate and I
think that's incredibly important and
why why would that not be a skill that
once that should be cultivated I mean
after all our salaries in most case are
paid by the public yeah I guess although
I also think it's a very foolish linear
attitude so if if I just sit there and
crank out publications that's going to
make better quality work that's just not
how how about happen you know you
sometimes you have to sleep and some
time
you have to eat and sometimes you have
to take a walk and clear your mind and
do something else and and to be
creatively you know we're not walking
off to write a manual for how to use a
Betamax which which might genuinely
degrade the quality of your scientific
that is useful yes but it is a whole
these are creative experiments you know
we are impacting the creative culture in
the conversation around science and
changing attitudes and so to my antidote
to what to the criticism you just level
but I think about doing as much sciences
I had the opposite situation with a
friend who said he had just published a
paper on the on the archive which is
where you share publicly your work and
it was rejected because it was the same
author list in the same title as a
previous paper they had written so like
that's not so great either right yeah
okay take a break creatively think about
something else put your mind to
something else and then like find the
enthusiasm and the freshness to come
back and and look at a new project yeah
I feel like it is I never remember which
hemisphere of the brain is responsible
for what aspect of human creativity but
and I think that means I am one of those
two brains and sort of saw solipsistic
describing in this book you know you get
the statement is false but I just love
it yeah I had always contemplated that
you know this this kind of all the
statement is false that girdle that
leads in this book which is a sort of
quote you know I view it as like
Schrodinger's book between fiction and
nonfiction because there's a lot of
nonfiction in it and there's a lot of
there's a lot of obviously fan fiction
and in a good sense but it's very
touching book as was your first book how
the universe got its spots I want to
take a step back and now talk about that
book and how it influenced you know my
life and just the way that I think about
things and I think this is an ideal way
to think about it so as I'm reading that
book I'm thinking about you know this is
as a young you know postdoc at Caltech
in the early 2000s mid 2000s and I was
thinking about well how could you
actually test some of these ideas that
Janna is discussing in the
and so I wanted to take the opportunity
to kind of walk back in time because
everyone's familiar with your you know
award-winning best-selling books this
this madman dreams of Turing machines
black hole blues which we'll get into in
a little bit but I want to take you back
to that first book and and because I
think it's it's so so charming and it's
influential in ways that you might not
have understood at the time to people
like me who build experiments and I want
to talk about that the interface between
you and the work that you do as a
theoretical physicist is a theoretical
cosmologist and the work that people
like me do which is to build instruments
and I've had on people like Sean Carroll
and and and others on the podcast and we
and as I said Eric Weinstein and it kind
of runs the gamut I think I've only had
one true experimentalist and that was
your colleague Elena Priya at Columbia
University and she was wonderful we
talked a lot about dark matter and xenon
what do you view as the fundamental
equivalent in in this book you talked a
lot about girdle's incompleteness
theorem which is the statement that
mathematics when encoded and encrypted
in a special way that you describe
really wonderfully in the book is
inconsistent that it's incomplete that
there are statements which cannot be
proven or disproven is that right yeah
well I think the choice is good or what
was faced with was either inconsistency
which would have been devastating or
encompass and and so he formulates his
proof believing that there will note
there will never be any outright paradox
something will never simultaneously be
true and false but there will be things
that are incomplete undecidable that you
will not be able to formally prove as an
axiom of a or sorry as a theorem of a
set of axioms that something is true or
false if there are simply facts about
numbers we will never know and one of
the examples I like to give is there are
numbers with an infinite list of digits
0.176 - and each digit is like a toss of
the coin there is no way to prove
predict no facts are true or false about
that list of numbers they are
uncomputable unknowable and therefore
arithmetic is incomplete so the shortest
way to describe them is by them there's
no
shorter more compactified way to
describe yeah so you know no with them
right you know we only deal with
computable numbers so soon of the
infinite set of numbers that we can deal
with there is a larger infinity that we
know nothing about I want to get I mean
you're just stimulating so many
different directions that I want to go
in but but before we leave girdle I want
to get back to infinity because I
believe that we can't even deal with
infinities and the human mind and and
not just writing down a symbol on a
piece of paper or when your kid tells
you I love you infinity hopefully but I
want I want to get back to girdle for
one second just to say that in my
opinion running around Vienna not too
long or too different in time was a was
a PhD or doctor named Sigmund Freud and
dr. Freud spoke about this concept a
certain type of envy which we won't get
into because it's a family show but he
talked about envy and I kind of
conjecture that physicists have
mathematician and B in the sense that we
don't have a crisp criterion that
mathematicians do thanks to girdle as
you describe in this book we don't have
a criterion to tell us what is good
science we typically will use popper and
we'll say popper says that if something
cannot be falsified it doesn't count as
science I always point out that he was
talking at the time when karl popper
conjectured that dialectic that that
dichotomy between what constitutes
science or not he was really talking
about the demarcation between things
like socialism and capitalism or
psychoanalysis like Freudian analysis
and and basically quackery or astrology
versus astronomy and it went you know he
sort of went to his grave where people
do take that as a cynic qua non of what
is physics let's say but we don't have a
crisp we can't compute it in the same
way that girdled provides as you
describe what do you make about this the
obsession that my colleagues and I have
with falsifiability you know because I
want to turn that obviously to your
theories of topology and spatial that
you brought forth and have the universe
got its spots so can you tell me how do
you as a theorist as a card-carrying
theorist look at what constitutes actual
good science
well I mean ice needs a very subtle
question I think there's a lot of danger
of moving away from falsifiability
mostly in the sense of it being
misunderstood so for instance I can
compute something about the shape of the
10 dimensional space and it is
falsifiable on my page even if they
cannot perform a different kind of
experiment to verify whether our
universe manifests in that way and in
that sense it might be that my theory
exceeds falsifiability because of our
human limitations maybe it'll happen in
300 years but doesn't not make it
science because it is a kind of an
experiment to look on the page and say
look there's this thing called a circle
it has diameter 2r and it has
circumference 2 PI R and why don't you
do the same experiment and you're gonna
find us an answer and it's totally
theoretical it only exists in our mind
but it's a real experiment and it is
falsifiable because if you go around you
ask a billion people if they know what
they're talking about we're all going to
agree that this circle is 2 PI R and
anyone who tries to build a bridge based
on a different principle the bridge is
gonna fall down right that's a form of
verifiability to me and and that's the
kind that I seek when I'm working if I
get 2 so for instance let's take good o
cuz it's a really wonderful example of
that where you could say somebody who's
not a scientist or mathematician might
say Oh we'll never know everything right
and or that's not knowable don't bother
and they don't understand the difference
between that attitude which is
completely psychological and not
verifiable how distinct it is from gödel
writing a proof proving that there are
facts that we will never know it's
verifiable we all can check his proof
and so sperry think that there's a
subtlety to these things now that leads
us to things like string theory maybe
maybe there's a multiverse of
possibilities and that's not verifiable
experimentally but the math mad
of it being a viable possibility for the
universe is falsifiable hmm so yes so
when you encode encrypt in ways that you
described then perhaps right we can have
a glimpse at the underlying
superstructure the reality veracity of
that without perhaps being able to
conclude something about that you know
what lies at the very top
folks like Weinstein and others you know
really conjecture that the pinnacle of
culture even civilization is theoretical
physics and that experimental physics in
he and I went back and forth on this
he's kind of like the tailor you know
who might put on the last button on a
suit or something like that and or a
theorist who makes an incremental
contribution what's that
yes he is he is he's so shy it's very
hard to get him out of this show so I
want to talk about the actual you know
subject of that book had the universe
guarded spots and in particular the
connection between topology the size the
shape of the universe because I do think
it's sort of underappreciated and not
only has led to searches in you know in
the field of experimental physics but
even other theorists like our friend
Glenn Starkman you know has also gone
off and is still fruitfully looking for
features of the universe that you
describe in the book so I looked it up
it was published in 2002 is that right
the book yeah it is terrible okay well
anyway it's a wonderful book don't say
yes I remember now you remember where
you were when you were turning the
physical page I mean before we had this
swiping left and swiping right
oh no that's a different app that's a
different app that I don't know but they
yeah so could you take us back to the
physics that caught the conjectures that
you were putting forth which are very
highly original and and what the status
of them are today so that work that you
mentioned with a colleague Glenn
Starkman and he was also working with
David Spergel and no Cornish it's a
really clever idea so maybe we'll get to
it Glenn's been on the show or he's
given a talk here and I've recorded on
the channel I'll put a link to it too so
pure audio explanation of this it's
pretty challenging but but but this part
isn't so true the idea
it's pretty simple you know Einstein
teaches us that our experience of
gravity is really an experience of a
space-time that really what we're doing
when we're experiencing the
gravitational pull of the Sun as a
planet is we're falling freely along a
curve in the shape of that orbit we're
not firing rockets we're actually
falling the whole time we're just
cruising along fast enough that we never
crash into the atmosphere of the Sun and
once an insight teaches us that you know
you start to say well space-time has one
time dimension in three space dimensions
I need to tell you where to meet me
north-south-east-west up and down in a
building and as well as the date can't
be a hundred years earlier or a hundred
years later and that's space-time we can
find each other there now as soon as you
think about that there becomes a common
question which is why three why should
universe be dimensional so this was
thought about very early on right away
actually people started to dabble in
theories of space-time that had more
spatial dimensions oh and then you yeah
you would back to Kaluza and Klein back
in the early 1900's 1920s and things so
beautiful things were discovered there
sorry can you hear my sirens yeah I can
hear it's okay New York City was yeah
that's right it's pandemic people living
in my own bizarre fantasy so so those
ideas part of the argument was if the
extra spatial dimension was small we
might not notice it and that's that's
really the conversation start so classic
example you're an ant walking on a straw
you're aware that there's a long
dimension you're a little less able to
explore the width of the stroke
especially as I shrink it smaller and
smaller you might believe you are only
on one dimension not two and so
similarly in there could be at every
point in space a wrapped-up manifold
like a little spacetime origami
that's all folded up it's spatially
small too small literally for me to put
my hand in it and and we
cannot rule that out and in fact there
are some advantages to it he brought up
Brian Greene Brian and I have thought
about well is it possible these extra
spatial dimensions are responsible for
dark energies possible we're observing
them you know so there's a lot of really
interestingly I love doing extra
dimensional cosmology but eventually you
do run out of things that you can you
can as you said verify and that just you
know yeah it means I'm about to meet
occasionally
and right well as I said it is extremely
influential and you may have be in luck
because in one of the top science
journals in the world is of course
published in your in your hometown
currently and that's the New York Post
and you know New York Post has a has a
an article yesterday that said NASA
scientists detect evidence of parallel
universe where time runs backwards and I
I point out as they say you know just
because it's published in the New York
Post doesn't necessarily mean it's wrong
they usually say that about nature so
this is a study that kind of really
could be pulled out of you know how the
universe got its got its clock or
something and they claimed I kind of
digressed here because oh yeah on it
universe contact spots yeah coming back
from this whole idea of extra spatial
dimensions and saying well when the
universe was born why would three
dimensions instantaneously be infinite
and the other dimensions stay wrapped up
and small hmm and how do universe got
spots was a point well maybe those large
dimensions and they're just very big
they're not actually infinite right that
they they are also compact like the
direction of the straw and it's just
really explaining like you know those
balloon tricks where you make an animal
balloon and you squeeze down the extra
dimensions maybe that blows out the
three large so yes there's some way
we're now we're looking more
holistically at a university
democratically totally wrapped up and
what you're trying to explain is why
three got big hmm flipping it around
flipping the script as our friend Stefan
would say
ah very interesting yeah that's that's
delightful way to think about it and I
think you know one one aspect of this
research so the reason I bring up this
New York Post article about you know
parallel universes is really to you know
kind of um highlight the fact that what
you work on is some of the most
interesting aspects of modern physics
and cosmology and the surprise is that
you know these things are unified - what
do you attribute the fascination the
public has in the very I mean they're
following you so they're interested in
black holes they're following you
they're interested in and you know
actually a spec so parallel dimensions
but besides that why are people so
interested in the multiverse in the
extra dimensions the arrow of time and
and things like black holes I it's funny
I think I can answer it because I can
answer it to some extent for myself it's
some combination of the strangeness and
the truth it's the idea that this is
something that transcends where you're
from in the world it transcends what
time what year you were born in and
presumably from a different galaxy these
are the strangest things you could think
of but they're true for all of us
and there's something about that
combination that I think is very
exciting whereas I can read something
that's completely fictitious and strange
and implausible and I don't get that
same excitement right so I'm getting
some excitement from walking away from
believing that they actually are real
mmm and that they're out there and that
is the physicist versus the
mathematician okay wanting to know that
it's not just a neat little problem on
my page and that somehow these thought
experiments are telling us things about
the universe 13 billion years ago and
there's just a that's incredibly moving
powerful and a sense of meaning and
connection and being progeny of the
universe it's all written I also see it
as a human story you and the same
tradition as Alan Lightman I don't know
if you interacted with him when you were
at MIT or not but you know I find you to
of you almost unique amongst you know
popularizers and
practicing scientists and that you could
write the most journalistic hardcore
fact reporting yeah you know on one hand
with black hole blues you can write
something in particular about about the
nature of a scientific theory which
might be a speculation many can write up
work of fiction as he's done and the
view as you did in this book madman
dreams of Turing machines what about
that I mean it was this sort of like you
going into a parallel universe where you
could control at least some of the
fictional aspects of these individuals
and get inside their minds maybe and
even today
yeah so how did that it attract you as a
writer as a thinker yeah I mean I love
reading fiction I just I just love
reading fiction and I by instinct with
read a lot more fiction than nonfiction
except that I also interview a lot of
people I get pioneering so I read a lot
I have to meet a lot of non-fiction
books but but I love language right so
if the world had been a different way
and I could not have pursued being a
physicist I think it's quite natural I
would have wanted to become a writer and
that you know we're not born with these
divisors in our brains and if anything I
think the bigger questions is why do we
outgrow being artists and scientist
every kid is a scientist
every single kid is palpating texting
measuring experimenting like how do we
why are we taught that we have some kind
of falsehood that we outgrow this so so
yes writing itself was always something
I love I just love language and so I
took very seriously the process of
writing itself of playing with words
experimenting with structure when you
brought up a madman dreams of train
machines and then that book like you
said it's kind of like the Schrodinger's
book of reality and fiction and in fact
I was doing I was playing on the theorem
itself that there are some true facts
that cannot be proven as a theorem
yielding out of the axioms right it's
not just a systematic list of steps and
you get to the truth and so in some
sense by by telling a lie by
fictionalizing I was I felt I was
getting in some sense closer to the
truth than if I had
and that biography doesn't have a
narrator or an author right and that and
the truth deforms under touch any book
that you write is automatically altering
the truth through the filter of your
perception the way you speak the way you
write the decisions you made as a
biographer and so I just decided just to
give over to it totally as the statement
and just call it fiction and and also
give myself a leeway to invent and in my
experience a nonfiction is very hard so
I think this fourth book that I'm
finishing is going to be my last
nonfiction for a while yeah it is well I
mean this this book you have a lyrical
style that is very unique to you
I don't think of another author like you
I mean there are as I said Lightman has
his genre but he's not actually
practicing in the same sense that you
are and even in black hole blues and
certainly in how a universe got spots
you're able to weave together these very
little you know lovingly lyrical you
know phrase it phrase it turns a phrase
and just capturing the essence of the
personality in a way that is on par with
obviously you won this pen award and
that is they don't hand those out and so
I think it's it's quite it's quite
impressive to do that at the end of its
conversation I'll ask you you know what
steps can people take to really delve
further into this craft as you've done
and maybe you'll say is it's impossible
maybe you'll say it's innate so I'm half
the bafta listener reader sorry half the
authors that I've had on you know
Freeman Dyson used to tell me a lot of
it was just you know is just kind of
luck and how he came out into the world
other people say you can work on it so
we'll get to that at the towards the end
I know you don't have too much time I do
want to get to a couple of things I just
do appreciate you saying that because
like I said the book to me is in its own
object yeah and it build it like I'm
building a sculpture yeah it's just
words but I want to be as careful as if
I was chiseling something in an art
studio yeah
like everything has to be thought
through over and over and over again and
you're playing with clay and structure
and anyway didn't mean to get a no it's
lovely and actually that's that'll be
our last topic that we discuss and the
standard set of topics that I have for
all my guests and that's Carl Sagan's
quote about the astonishment of a book
which I actually had the pleasure to
read to his daughter Sasha when she was
a guest a couple weeks ago on our
special Mother's Day episode I will get
to that and I have a finger puppet of
him so it's it's appropriate that I'll
mention that towards the end before we
leave the topic of your next book I want
to talk about things that you're
interested in current cutting-edge
research obviously you thrilled and you
had a one-year anniversary of the event
horizon telescope detection of a
measurement of the event horizon mmm 87
and I'm wondering if you know the new
the new book if you could give us a
preview of it you've also given a
delightful lecture that's actually very
accessible even to lay people or people
like me who aren't you know
card-carrying theorists at Brown
University we'll put a link to that
colloquium and is that was that sort of
a preview you're talking about the black
hole battery or you know the black hole
pulsar yeah can you tell us a little bit
about your cut your current research and
how that can be feathered into your
upcoming book if it is well just as an
aside so I had Shep Dola man who's the
project director of the founding
director of the event horizon telescope
and Andy's rominger who's a brilliant
string theorist from Harvard in a
conversation together about a month
after the announcement last year and it
was it's and we just published it on the
broadcast yeah so you can watch the
whole conversation and it's so wonderful
like spontaneous applause from the
audience when we would build the image
even though they had already seen it a
month ago but it's just was so
incredible that they succeeded so so
going back to my own work I the
supermassive black holes are very
interesting to me some of the stuff I do
relates to that so the tricky thing
about what event horizon telescope did
was it had to find the biggest black
hole it could find that was the closest
so that you know I can take a marble and
I can see it but if I take a marble and
put it at 26,000
years I obviously can't see it so
there's a black hole the center of our
galaxy it's four million times the mass
of the Sun but what people don't realize
these black holes are small and ones
like black holes or these monsters
playing the whole point is that they're
tiny so you if you looked at the Sun on
the sky and you kind of imagine 17 with
servicemen across in that space you're
crushing four million Suns so it's it's
impressively small actually and at
26,000 light years they compare that to
resolving a piece of fruit on the moon
to try to take the picture of that and
m87 is of course the one that was
actually discovered it's much further
away but it's also much bigger so that
it's about the same size 55 million
light years away but six-and-a-half
billion times the mass of the Sun so I
was at the announcement was very excited
about that but a lot of my work is about
how to light up black holes lately and
so it might be a supermassive black hole
or it might be a black hole that formed
from stellar collapse it's not so big
and and one of the cool ideas this is
something you know it probably just also
came out of teaching I was given
electricity and magnetism he as my
curriculum mom about these funny things
if you take like you have a light back
here if I were to unplug my light bulb
and I had a big magnet and I waved a
magnet around I would create electricity
and light up that light bulb it's it's a
stunningly strange fact it's just
electricity and magnetism so here I'm
thinking okay home is dark black hole
and next to it might be a neutron star
which is a dead star that doesn't quite
make it to be at fault small but not as
small and and they they are giant
magnets and so this neutron stars
whipping around this black hole so now I
have a magnet that's waving around it
must create electric fields it's the
idea those electric fields can light up
the light bulb of the black hole neutron
star cyst so it's it's it's a very cool
little idea and it's something that
would be very hard to see from far away
that we can't be sure we've seen it
where
looking for it and so as these things
merge and if we were to get the ringing
of the space time through the
gravitational waves we could hear them
and see a flash of light that's part of
the hope and then this idea of a black
hole becoming a pulsar is the idea that
the black hole will acquire its own
magnetic field in this process and it
will become its own magnet and a pulsar
is a neutron star with a huge magnetic
field and so if I take a black hole and
I put a huge magnetic field on it in the
same way it should emulate a lot of the
features of the Pulsar which is to say
to power Jets as it spins around and and
so we could look for something like a
black hole pulsar so this could be a
multi Multi messenger type signal firm
from such a non-white and neutron stars
collide because they're made of these
incredibly superconducting unbelievably
condensed materials what we did see was
a series of fireworks literally like
fireworks like there's this and if it's
followed by that and then there's a
different explosion and you know it went
on for a year and it was probably the
most widely studied event in the history
of astronomy yeah right and and black
hole blues of course is this paon - you
know detecting sort of the Silence of
space-time but the vibrations of
space-time due to this coalescence and
and really the human story of the LIGO
team and and trying to come to fruition
and but but really it's this sort of a
silent film I think that's what you call
it you call it a sort of the you know
most most important silent film ever
made in some sense but now you're
talking about you know a real well maybe
a I don't know what the opposite is a
talkie or something like that but where
you now have not only sound which you
have light right so so you're adding a
soundtrack to the universe yeah and
we're seeing things in the past so we
really it is like we're seeing those we
recorded two black holes colliding 1.3
billion years ago
at a time when multicellular organisms
were just differentiating on the earth
it's just it's just kind of wild to
think about that coming towards us over
1.3 billion years well we evolved
Einstein lives we build instruments put
them out there and then there's this
like yeah actually I had Mario Livio on
the podcast a couple weeks ago for his
new book Galileo and the science deniers
and he and the nd sort of summarizes
what he would you know sort of use to
convey how far humanity has come in a
single sentence and it's that you know
but we've detected black holes
coalescing you know from million light
years away it's sort of the pinnacle of
all of civilization because you know so
much encrypted in that so I know you
don't have too much time I want to
finish up this discussion so the new
book will be out in the fall or winter
we're sore late 2020 maybe early 2021 we
hope to have you back on maybe in person
we still won't need mass but I'll
provide you with Simon's here we'll have
our own sounds Observatory grant mask
that a friend designed with the Columbia
manifold on it the six dimension and
extra spatial dimensions from string
theory it's well I just have a black
halt because that's what my mother said
so I want to turn to to wrap up this
this conversation with with some
questions that I asked all of my guests
and I tried to really dig into a little
bit of their own personality on these
questions but it kind of standardizes
things and and makes it nice for the
audience to sort of tie together
different episodes from these different
brilliant scholars and I'm blessed to
have on the podcast so the first one is
something we kind of alluded to earlier
which is that you know books are sort of
this magical DNA that that that connects
human beings throughout the throughout
the eons and none other than Carl Sagan
said the following he said what an
astonishing thing a book is it's a flat
object made from a tree with flexible
parts and which are imprinted lots of
funny dark squiggles but one glance at
it and you're inside the mind of another
person maybe somebody dead for thousands
of years across the millennia an author
is speaking clearly and silently inside
your head directly to you and I want to
ask you about all your books mate
but yeah so beautiful too you know kind
of talk to Sasha say again about this
wonderful quote that's so influential to
me and and many other people and her
book of course is about her parents and
also about her daughter and her new
rituals that she's establishing on this
small little marble on the Sunnis the
pale blue dot as her father would say so
I want to ask you first I've heard it
said by some authors that they trade a
hundred readers a year from now for one
reader a hundred years from now and I
want to ask you of your books and you
could choose any one of them besides the
book sales let's say you know in a
hundred years the book will cost a
hundred times as much what you prefer
what a tough question it's like asking
about your kids or something to pick one
I used to ask my mom that I used to say
mom you know we have I have three
brothers and I say mom you know which
kid is your BIP favorite and she'd say
that's like asking me to choose which
arm I like better I said mom you're a
left-handed person yeah it's dad would
be really hard I think because my
relationship with my books isn't isn't
my readers relationships my books I mean
to a large extent the first book was
very special because it was so
unselfconscious I didn't think anyone we
would read it it was it was very much a
message on the bottom and so I was very
surprised that that book had a tough
life and had an audience and was a
wonderful experience then the second
book is a lot scarier because then
suddenly you're like you're it's stuff
at stake and and so I think that's why
that book is so different I couldn't
repeat what I had already done and so I
I just figured you know people often
forgive your second book in the shadow
of your first so a madam in terms of
training machines I got totally
experimental I delved into the whole
fictional side and for me I cannot
understate how it felt like I had opened
new doors in my own mind mmm like wombs
I didn't know existed hmm and so for me
it's I don't know for a reader yeah but
for me that becomes what was so
important about that
and then black coal blue systems such a
love letter to the experiments to Ray
and KITT and very and the people
involved some of the people who didn't
even get named who I just you know I'd
loved and worked with and and struggled
with so I don't think I can answer that
question I am sorry to say okay that's
fine that's the guests prerogative to
answer it oh yeah I've heard people
answer everything you know from venal I
want as many sales of the book now as
possible
I interviewed Sarah fryer who wrote a
book about Instagram and a founding of
Instagram which kind of it's been called
you know the social network equivalent
for Instagram it's a lovely wonderful
book and she was like yeah I definitely
people to read it now like a hundred
years from now who knows what Instagram
they don't even know what that is that's
like your Betamax your Betamax manual
that I can't wait for you to write
another question about books so in terms
of readers not numerically but sort of
quantity or the disposition of the
readers would you rather have somebody
you know we've all gotten negative
reviews of our work or creative work and
obviously our you know our kind of day
jobs as physicists we used to that kind
of criticism yeah so which would you
rather have pick up this book if you
could force somebody to read it
cover-to-cover really digest it really
grapple with it would you rather have a
hater you know the the the player hater
you know of the Jan 11 set or a our
fanboy like me you know who would you
rather have read and let's just go
through the three books I mean the
haters you know that's not criticism and
that's not critique and so I learned a
lot from hard criticism and critique
from my editor
mm-hm or a friend who's read it they're
not haters it's not haters but I really
mean like skeptic or someone you know
whose whose and it kind of takes a
contra factual perspective yeah you know
I don't like I don't enjoy arguing about
the Flat Earth yes
and I don't enjoy trolls who are you
know okay I don't mean to call like why
is it so important why yeah you know I
really believe as a reader that the
experience of a book is part the right
or in part the reader and it's like that
beautiful quote you just read from Carl
Sagan that somebody is speaking to you
and you're in your head yet yet you are
the one animating that speaker so
there's this there's this meeting of
personalities and psyches and the
experience of a book so no book is
experienced to the same by all readers
it's not like this is the book yeah and
this is how you will receive it so I'm
very interested in a whole range obvious
and responses to that because it's just
fascinating what some people are drawn
to and what other people found
uncomfortable mmm so I can handle the
person who says you know I could not
read that chapter about Turing dying
where you denied I couldn't you know and
and I can sympathize with that but and
it's interesting it's fascinating so I
love that that that it's an interplay
between reader and author and and I've
been listening to books lately and it's
not the same to to not have the control
of how you've animated that character in
your own interpretation mm-hmm
hearing your own voice in your own mind
yeah you're being influenced by another
voice yes right and that's there's
something that's why their books still
exist even after film no different books
because we want that quiet experience of
conjuring up in our own imagination what
that house looked like what that felt
like
and and that intimacy is very special
there was a you're on the Steven
Strogatz his podcast called the joy of X
which was his book the joy of X my going
to farming that's right
that's right you could call it your
podcast will be a mad girl dreams of
so in one of those episodes he talks
about the difference between music being
much more emotionally evocative with one
of the guests I forget who it is
and versus you know the painted art you
know two-dimensional art and he he
claimed the the gas to name I think he's
at the Institute for Advanced Study but
I'm not 100% sure I think was it the
string theorists was the Institute to
pronounce Dutch name yes exactly
anyway listener I'll link to it in the
show notes but anyway they are the the
the physicist who's speaking he's saying
you know it's deeper to listen to music
because you it's it's one-dimensional it
flows towards you at its own pace and
you can't change the speed of it you
can't alter it so you must confront it
on its own time scale whereas art you
can kind of take in the visual arts you
know all at once and the and the AI is
sort of more shallow less deep than the
heart or the ear and I think that's even
what maybe more so if music is to under
one-dimensional maybe reading is zero
don't know you're only taking in one
squiggle at a time in Carl Sagan's
language so I agree with you 100% the
the next question is you strike me as
someone who's just very a boolean very
optimistic has a very positive worldview
of course I've never you know been in a
faculty meeting with you I'm sure I'm
sure I'd see a different side of you but
everyone you know all of our mutual
friends paint you as as his ball of
energy Amanda Veltman said something
like you know when you were pregnant
with your second child I think it was
like you were this dynamo who is equally
tall as wide you know and it's just like
you said that you were like such a model
for how to be this complete human being
I don't know what it is about Columbian
Barnard cuz I really I really find the
frankness and approach of you and Elena
and Brian obviously so refreshing and
it's really wonderful I'm trying to
encourage Elena to write a book so
hopefully we'll get her today she's
terrific but speaking about optimism and
pessimism you're an optimist what are
you pessimistic about in particular how
do you perceive the post kovat fallout
afflicting our work in education and
outreach so the optimist in me wants to
sue because I'm also playing an
editorial role in
the broadcast I want to Commission an
article and this will speak to the
optimism that's titled something to the
effect we stopped everything to protect
ourselves
what will we stop to protect the planet
so I do think if there's a place in
which this horrible kovat experience
could teach us lessons about
environmental protection about our
academic structures you know about
riding bikes versus cars about flying
around the world so much that we
actually we do okay we did okay for the
two months of course the real problem is
the economic collapse right people not
having work and food yes it's not so
good I can't fly to Spain as much as I
really wanted to do that so I think it
was a brutal lesson for a lot of us that
actually we are contributing things that
we could individually stop we are
contributing harm to the planet things
that we could choose to stop but just it
could be some really wonderfully
optimistic lessons and I feel the same
way about academia that I realized when
I was kicked out of the classroom on to
zoom how much of that dynamism of
teaching is about being in that room
with your heads looking at their faces
knowing it's a very human interaction
and it simply is not the same over the
zoom and how I struggled with that and
it made me feel bad like I didn't feel
good about it you know it was it was
really tough and I think that instead of
immediately reverting to old norms maybe
we'll learn something about that process
you know an understanding a
reexamination of what was still
wonderful about being in the classroom
and and maybe it'll help us you know
update our systems in a way that's
really hard to meet a very intransigent
very hard to update just philosophically
for philosophical motivations it's very
different when it's life or death
yes sure and so so the optimist in me
thinks that if we're smart about and if
it means enough to us as much as our own
health and safety meant that we could do
things post kovat that we'll have
incredibly
positive influences on the way the world
plays out the last question I ask you is
based on a quote from Soren Kierkegaard
which i think is appropriate for
astronomers like ourselves and and
that's what he said was that life can
only be understood backwards but it must
be lived forwards and the title of the
podcast is the into the impossible
podcast and it's one of its one of Sir
Arthur C Clarke's Three Laws the first
of which being any sufficiently advanced
civilization is indistinguishable from
magic another one being for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
then the third one is the only way to
find out what is possible is to go
beyond and venture into the impossible
that's where our podcast gets its name
here at the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination
i want to ask you what does a
20-something 30-something
you know seemed impossible to you and it
could be anything that having gone
venturing into the impossible you'd like
to advise yourself about you know go
back in time and advise yourself that
it'll work out what seemed impossible
but now is possible eminently because
you ventured into the impossible well I
mean I could take a personal approach to
that question in which case wouldn't
have been impossible just daunting right
I I do think so I wasn't the kid who had
a chemistry set maybe he's MIT or
anything like that and I I came late to
physics I started studying it and
college and and I think that I found I
had those moments of how could I
possibly catch up on this subject when
some you know the guy next to me he's
been doing pretty advanced physics since
like his sophomore year in high school
right at MIT is probably not so uncommon
five year Prelude on me and his dad is
like famous experimentalist something
and um you know that got me down for
well I've struggled I struggled with
that and I think most scientists
until they get something under their
belt that really feels like them so even
if I published a few things but I felt
like I was doing what you know maybe my
advisor wanted or my some other
colleague mentor and when I until you do
something we think oh that was so that
was such a weird way of approaching the
problem that somebody else might have
solved it but that guy solved it in this
weird way and then you know this like
feeling of like oh my god it's like
finishing a Rubik's key it's your brand
it now becomes your own brand right and
I think like I'm kind that's kind of my
breath so like I don't write long papers
anymore page as a page as a pages page
if I can't figure out how to solve it
shorter you know then I haven't really
done my thing so I might just not
publish it right
so part of what I'd like to to do and
explore my work is these interesting
ways of cracking the wall not open but I
think even more so more than that sort
of personal stuff is when I discovered
things that I would have thought were
physically impossible and you confront
it in the mathematics on the page and
you did like it hits you in the solar
plexus that you really have to change
your mind open your mind to something
that seemed absolutely inconceivable
that is like one of the greatest
experiences it is it is both terrifying
because you feel some smallness of not
having the vision the foresight to be
open-minded to something to have had to
fight it fight the math and then and
then be forced to change your conclusion
it is just a great experience all around
so so yeah if I ever realize that some
things are possible that it seemed
impossible it's it can be very it could
be very exciting yeah well Jen I want to
thank you so much I want to now enter
into the plug zone is where I want to
promote you on Twitter and we're all
following you there at channel 11 you
have a website
you also have pioneer works website and
I want to for the audience listening out
there we're gonna give away a copy of of
either black hole Blues or madman dreams
of Turing machines for listeners on the
iTunes version of the podcast I want to
say thank you so much Jennifer joining
us today I will delight delight be
delighted if you'll come back again when
black hole Survival Guide is out on the
shelves later on this year hopefully or
early next year Thank You Janice so much
for sharing your mind your ideas Thanks
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic if you
enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent guest
newest book send a screenshot of your
review to info at imagine UCSD edu we
appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination dot UCSD edu find us on
Twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
YouTube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production of the arthur
c clarke center for human imagination in
the division of physical sciences at the
University of California San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco